south carolina senator lindsey graham
senator good to see you let me read this
very specifically
is we got doram's team now is arguing a
strong intersection between christopher
steele michael sussman and their
allegations against donald trump and
prosecutors on durham's team argued in
federal court today about this this
strong intersection
and what's interesting is sussman's
defense attorneys they're saying well no
christopher steele is a lightning rod
and argued that introducing anything
about him or his work would be
prejudicial towards their client now did
hillary clinton but
did she not buy that dirty russian
disinformation dossier was that
unverifiable dossier used as the basis
for four fisa warrants on carter page
and a backdoor to donald trump
well the whole narrative that trump
colluded with russia is being replaced
by
clinton's campaign
spread disinformation about trump's
relationship with russia fusion gps was
not advising the clinton campaign
about libel laws they were actually
spreading articles claiming trump was
colluding with russia and it was all
manufactured and made up so when sussman
goes to the fbi and says i've got
information that alpha bank and russia
has a backdoor connection to the trump
campaign which was all bs they asked him
why are you doing this are you connected
to the clinton campaign he said no and
that's why he's in the ringer so how did
mueller miss this how did the fbi miss
this we need a refund on the mueller
investigation how could horowitz find
that the dossier was a bunch of garbage
how could durham find that there was
collusion between fusion gps and the
clinton campaign with the media to smear
trump and mueller miss all of this
well it goes a little deeper though
remember horowitz made referrals and
nobody followed up on them for the very
same things other people had you know
early morning raids on their home with
guns drawn and even fake news cnn
cameras in some cases but the question
here is if you have hillary clinton and
her influence over the dnc
they funnel money to a law firm perkins
cooley the highest fusion gps an op
research firm that hired christopher
steele
uh that creates a series of documents
now known as the dossier right then the
dossier is used now the question is is
dorm getting to the raw nerve
or the intersection that matters here
and that is this was all drummed up by
hillary and all spread out by her
supporters knowing none of it was
verified or verifiable in other words
was it a lie from the beginning who knew
what and when what did they know when
did they know it
that's the ultimate question a campaign
lawyer for clinton mr sussman went to
the fbi with a story that the trump
campaign was connected to russian bank
they asked him are you involved with the
clinton campaign he said no so what do
we know now that fusion gps was
spreading disinformation about trump
russia we know that a lawyer for the
clinton campaign went to the fbi to tell
a lie to them about a connection between
trump and a bank in russia and we now
know that the carter page warrant was
illegally obtained because the steele
dossier was a bunch of crap so here's
the question how could the person
whose campaign was being run not know
any of this did hillary clinton know
that her team was spreading lies
throughout the media into the fbi to
make trump look bad regarding russia was
she in on it and i hope durham keeps
asking those questions i think
my gut tells me yes and that a lot of
people knew and a lot of people had no
problem because they felt the ends
justified the means and they didn't like
donald trump that much and look what
they put the country through hell over
nothing but a debunked conspiracy theory
hoax and a lie it's all true sad
all right senator thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else